last time what was the last year you
were wrong was it 80s was it nice if
it's happened then I'm just curious man
it's been a long time no because I mean
I mean I'm seriously I'm talking about I
am and if I if I say something I said
something that was incorrect on on the
air the other day another day we came in
from the break I said let me correct uh
information I gave you it's like boom
because okay here's the philosophy
here's a philosophy if you're driving
down the street or if you're watching
yeah and somebody says something and no
one says anything yeah yeah you go
that must be correct no one says
anything so what happens is especially
in cable news or even on Broadcast News
they will sit there and they will just
let people say stuff yeah and just slide
and I'm sitting there going
so
we just gonna sit here and just let that
lie just stand and then it's kind of
like okay now we have time no that was a
lie and then what they'll do is then I
hate this well we'll come back in fact
take the next day no no you fact check
in the moment but the problem is most of
these people who are television anchors
they are not smart they're not well read
and they have they rely on a producer to
have to fact check them provide them
facts whereas for me no we're gonna fact
check in real time like right right now
you say something yeah and my whole deal
is you're talking I'm sitting there on
my iPad I remember Michael Singleton was
we working with the uh Ben Carson
campaign he goes no rolling Ben Carson
has an HBCU plan I'm like no he doesn't
he's like I guarantee I'm like smart you
know what schmeichel
I said why don't you make your point and
I'm gonna sit over here and go to his
website so go ahead and finish your
point so he's talking I'm sitting there
I'm
I'm like are you done
um and I had this phrase Shelley was my
director I'll go and so anytime my
audience knew when I say Shelly go to my
iPad
somebody's but I'm about to get in
somebody's ass it's about to happen
right now and I went Shelly go to my
iPad
sure Michael this is his website
this is the search box
HBCU click
do you see any like it's on the screen
and he's sitting there it's like oh God
and I'm just and I'm killing them and
I'm like dude you I said and we we just
break our sister Michael never ever go
on the air and be emphatic with
something if you had not checked before
you said it
and to this day he's gotten other
television he thanks because I put him
on TV first he said you taught me a
valuable lesson he said you handed my
ass to my said because you didn't fact
check before came out of your box yeah I
mean listen you see that happen on a lot
and you know I I'd love to see
a system where during elections so we
did this one debate one time where we
had this guy who was Pro uh uh she was
from a normal she was a director of
normal to legalize marijuana and the
other guy was a Navy intelligence guy
captain and they came and we were doing
this uh sit down five six years ago and
the way we did it which was fascinating
is every time a person gave a fact or a
statement with Rita the bottom would say
and then it would show red or it would
say green yes this is exactly what there
you go I would level format that both
candidates Republican Democrat every
time they say something a fact check we
should have the technology for people to
be able to do that today though but you
don't have to actually wait for them to
say yes or no to that now because you
got these debates you just do it no you
just do it yeah and and and so what do
you think CNN ABC Fox what do you think
these guys well because it's an inside
game it's an inside game well the game
is you like you like the invitation you
want to invite them back so you want to
make them happy and so you don't want to
take them off until the show is like oh
no so we so we're going to go soft if
you will as opposed to you know both
sides do that go hard right so you take
so September this is September 21 I'm on
ABC news this week and Chris Christie
gave his big speech at the Reagan
Library you know we need to move on from
Trump whatever so we're sitting there
and so and again I'm just a guest right
okay I'm not a contributor the other
three people contributors George
Stephanopoulos is sitting right there
and so I'm like during the break they
said we could talk about Chris
Christie's speech and the uh forgot the
sister she uh she said you shouldn't go
talk about that to George and she he
goes yeah no I'm I'm not saying anything
inside I'm like oh hell yes bring this
speech up please bring this speech up so
comes up and so George talks and Chris
is talking and he's you know taking his
very high and mighty stance and I'm and
I'm sitting there and it's like you go
back and watch it I'm waiting because
see this is why I teach people you can't
be too eager to jump in so you you to
let it come to you so he talks and
they're talking back and forth and then
she talks and then she talks and then
George gets to me and I make my and I
turn to Chris Christie and I say you
have to accept responsibility you play
in creating that man
and I and I just went right at him and
he's like you know I ran against him in
2016 but you debate prepped him in 2020
and you support he was I'm talking about
he turns red to be fair I mean to be
fair like this is like uh uh the one
thing about politics it's you saw Kamala
calling out Biden yes immediately and
then boom she's the VP yes George H.W
bush called Reagan's economic policies
Voodoo economic and then boom right yes
but but again though but you accept the
fact that you did it so remember he she
she's totally fine right you know she
called him out she called them out and
they became VP my Pro my problem with
Christy right was you're giving this
huge speech like he was this problem of
the problem and I'm sitting there going
yes but you created the monster so it's
so like you can't complain about the
monster when you create when you help
create the monster when there was an
option to say
I have convictions morals principles and
values I simply cannot stand with a
known liar right and what I say it is
you chose politics and power over
principles and patriotism happens on
both sides right all the time yeah I
never said it doesn't the point is you
have to be willing to actually say it so
when somebody so if you say okay I was
very much against this here now I'm for
it okay but and then if it blows up
don't try then don't try to come back
and go well I mean I knew everything was
going to blow up no no no no no no no
you didn't stand on principle and I
think that's that's that's a huge
problem today when we look at not just
politics but also business we have
people I'm going back to the whole point
about when I was in the kindergarten if
you have to be willing to stand on truth
knowing
it's going to cost you
and when you when you can accept that
to me this is just me yeah I'm going to
sleep a lot better because I'm simply
not going to just go along to get along
if I actually have conviction that this
person is not it I don't care what they
do and what they promise I can't stand
with you right not going to happen so so
okay so so that's good that you're
saying that because I I like stats I
like data okay to go through some data
and we'll cover some of that because I
truly want to get your opinion my ideal
situation would be to have a panel of of
folks from both sides to debate and have
a conversation together civilly I think
that's the way where the audience wins
uh where you're able to say here's what
I believe the other person says what I
believe and then there is the facts
meaning I got new to us for you there's
a not both sides what do you remember
how about you have a debate see again
though see this is this is where the it
this is because again I lived it see
when it's both sides
because when I say I lived it they would
speak the truth in The Green Room
but when they go in the air what happens
is their side their tribes are watching
so they defend the tribe versus the
issue so here's why I told CNN why don't
we have some debates where you actually
have two Republicans who disagree on the
issue that way you take party out now
becomes the issue the problem today in
most debates we're not debating the
issue we're debating the sides when you
debate the issue it's not your Democrat
you're Republican you're left you're
right you're blue you're red no no
what's the issue and so when people have
said to me they're like I've never
self-identified as a Democrat or
Republican I refuse have I voted for
republicans and Democrats yes because I
look at what's this issue I'm a huge
school choice person yeah oh I've had
some Democrats who have who and I'm like
y'all want to swing let's swing and the
Republicans are going well man you stay
with us on this issue I'm like no I
don't stand with you in terms of the
party on the issue I stand with the
issue but gender that's the problem we
have today but we don't discuss the
issue well so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]